[Music]
oh my goodness you guys i'm so freaking
excited because we have a special guest
we have sylvia
aka mama latina
thank you for coming thank you for
inviting me oh my gosh so it's so crazy
if you guys remember i made the leo
recipe
it was her recipe from her blog and i
shouted her out and i was like hey if
you want to collab let's collab and she
was like
yeah what really oh my god i feel so
honored so i have been following her
vlog for a long time now because i've
been wanting to incorporate more mexican
cuisine into this household and your
recipes are just so amazing so delicious
and i finally
built up the courage to make the first
one which is the polio recipe and now
we're gonna be making pumpkin
so this time you're with me so i feel
like oh my gosh i get to learn from the
teacher directly i know it's so fun and
we're going to make a a very easy recipe
that is like a nice combination between
mexican and american right yeah just in
time for thanksgiving yeah because you
know we love pumpkin seeds
yeah which is the pumpkin but the way we
we eat it is just in dulce in like a
candy and like uh yeah with this kind of
syrup and then yeah
this is like a pumpkin pie now nut
you know in spanish how we call meats
all of it is just me like i didn't
really know the differences of like
different types of animals like no one
really calls it like by the animal
anyway the point is i don't know the
difference between atole and champurado
so what is well so the champurrado is
that kind of a total okay right so when
we talk about atoles it's a horn-based
beverage right so you can either use
cornstarch
or masa oh
like a thick form and it gives a more
earthy flavor to the atole yeah and the
cornstarch is the flour so that gives um
for me it's like silkier and more not a
sporty but i like it better right my mom
used to make a dolly with cornstarch how
i learned it and how i do
we're gonna pour the milk in the pot
first and then i also i purposely got
la la milk which is a mexican brand yeah
and how you gonna eat this one
oh
i don't know we're gonna make some oh
yeah
tamales
okay there you go
then we're gonna add cinnamon
and you did it right because we need to
explain that to people because sometimes
you find this cinnamon that is like very
hard hard so you need to make sure that
you get the the mexican oh i call it
mexican maybe it's not let's see how is
uh you see a lot of layers in the
cinnamon that's the one you need because
sometimes you find one that is just one
layer oh and it smells like cinnamon but
never breaks and you need this to break
all the flavor and break out the smell
that's good enough right
just to get all the
and everything is out
and i just throw it right now right like
okay the good thing about the toilet is
that you can choose the amount of
sweetness that you want okay because
it's always it's always better to add if
you need more yeah and for some people
it's too sweet it depends how you want
it so let's just do that and play with
the flavors okay and now
we are going to a little bit of a little
bit of this and now and i'm going to
explain you why when you combine milk
with a fruit or a veggie that is a
little acidic yeah
we say mexico
which is like the milk breaks yeah you
start seeing all these dots on it baking
soda will help us with it okay so it's
going to be like a pinch okay that's it
so now we're gonna put this on the stuff
and we're gonna get a boiling
[Music]
perfect
in the color right so we're just gonna
get one cup yeah so the pumpkin is a
little bit um has a lot of body right so
it's gonna help with it
with the thickness of the atole so we're
gonna use a lot less starch that i would
use on another atollas okay and then we
are going to
mix our cornstarch on one cup of milk so
we're gonna put like this is a big cup
yeah so let's just do half
so we're gonna add
for now just a couple
now stir until everything is dissolved
so remember it has to be cold okay yeah
so now it's time to go back to milk with
this too yeah and we're just gonna keep
stirring and you're gonna add the
pumpkin puree okay and the importance to
do that is that uh we don't want it to
break so i'm going to keep moving we've
been moving
we don't want to break them you want to
break the milk how do you say that in
english because we say it's a court in
espanola
yeah if that happens to you yes which
you're gonna notice that you do like
this and you see how it is like all all
soft yeah here if it wasn't like a broke
breaking you see a lot of white spots
okay so if that happens to you you
remove it from the heat okay
you pour it but you uh um you uh strain
it strain it because you have all and
you put it on your blender you just
blend it and that fix it okay and then
you put it back and then you put it back
okay and that's and that's good to know
yeah okay so now we're gonna add the
cornstarch and we're gonna continuously
stir
and the reason for that is that um if
you don't stir it tends to stick to the
bottom yeah you don't want anything
that's a little bit burnt and you don't
want to what are we looking for for the
thickness the thickness okay yeah so
right now it's as you can see it's very
yeah watery very watery yeah but as they
start boiling it's gonna start
thickening okay but it's not easy at all
nice nice so easy
yeah a few ingredients and you can make
it with different fruits
yeah oh yeah so what would be the
difference if let's say i wanted to make
guava so for guava you need to cook the
guava with sugar before okay until it's
completely cooked
yes okay you know i'm gonna try to make
one with like peanut butter yeah peta
could be super easy oh yeah i'm really
delicious yeah i mean just put the sugar
in the milk and the cinnamon and then
you just add peanut butter that's what
i'm thinking
[Music]
is that thickening yeah slightly yeah
let's start getting silky and
nice looks so good
i kind of wish we made a big old pot
like how long would it last uh well it's
hard to say because my husband last we
just eat it
nice you know what do you think is that
thickening
yeah a little bit
it's getting more body but it's not
still thick
oh my god it smells
so good oh my gosh
i love it oh the cinnamon and the
pumpkin and the milk oh my god
oh this smells so good i'm just gonna
make this just to
make my house smell good oh my gosh my
mouth is so watery so how thick do you
like your atole
um like i said i'm really new to antonio
i'm used to chamborado thickness so um
and what is this
thickness for you what i'm used to is
pretty thick it's pretty thick yeah but
i'm totally open to not having it super
thick whatever whatever you recommend
i like it some body on it but not super
thick that
yeah you need it and i cannot drink it
yes
yeah i had tempura it's so thick you
need a spoon yeah you know what i think
i'm gonna make this on thanksgiving day
because i'm trying to i'm planning on
making a pumpkin dessert of some sort
maybe pumpkin pie or pumpkin pie
cheesecake maybe pumpkin
uh oatmeal cookies i don't know
something and then you make the pumpkin
natalie so it's pumpkin pumpkin yes i
love them you can never have too much no
you know what i do i actually the
pumpkin season i get a bunch of pumpkin
uh cans so i can make pumpkin pie any
time of the year i love it i don't care
if it's not thanksgiving yeah i'm going
to like why is pumpkin only for the fall
i know what is it oh good
oh yeah it's boiling yeah so we're going
to lower the
the volume now we're going to lower the
temperature i just keeps stirring my mom
taught me recently um to make refried
beans from a can to add milk and you
probably take the flavor a little bit so
they can't flavor oh
i'm going to try that that's cool i get
to pass on a trick from my mom to mama
because i usually make my beans you know
from a scratch but sometimes i want
beans and i don't have beans and i don't
want to wait for them so a can of beans
is always yeah just as the best
breakfast milk that's my mom's oh good
tip there i'm gonna do that look at this
yeah
so it has a little bit of body see when
you do this and it's all smooth it means
that it didn't break oh nice yeah so
let's just turn it off
and now with a toilet wait a little bit
okay like 10 minutes because it's super
hot and it really came oh yeah you'll
break it
yeah i can i easily burn my tongue yeah
so all my hot drinks are like lukewarm
okay
that's it
that's super easy
i could totally do this all the time
honey how do you feel i'm ready for this
all the time
bring it on ready for the toilet yay i'm
so excited so we're gonna strain it
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
almost there
[Music]
every drop
a moment of truth
okay here we go i'll just pour a little
a little bit because we also i you know
we need to try from uh sweetness
[Music]
it's fine
it is sugar yeah
yeah it's really good though
it needs more sugar
[Music]
oh i got the back of my throat yes hot
oh that's so good oh man
i want to be sitting on a rocking chair
in el rancho
in like sunset right now
let's imagine that's close
hearing the cricket
and it's a little sugar but it's very
good okay one two
because i like my atoll sweet i don't
know you but okay perfectly okay
i mean a tiny bit thicker wouldn't hurt
but yeah this is perfect i think sorry
gosh
[Music]
well that's really good mm-hmm honestly
i'm not big on you yeah it's gonna say
this is perfect
that would be perfect for me okay let's
try with sugar
[Music]
because we're not patient we're just
kidding
oh much better man yeah oh yeah we like
oratory sweet yes so now we just need
something a tamalitos
in there you know how we how you guys
can get it mama latinatips.com
perfect for thanksgiving yeah exactly me
pumpkin season right so many yummy
things you can make and try
mmm oh i can't i'm not gonna keep
drinking this right it's so good it's
not gonna last you know ask me how long
you're gonna last you're slowly you're
not gonna last for 24 hours no i had a
blast thank you so much and i'm just so
excited to now know how to make a tole
and i can try it with different flavors
different flavors and i'll be texting
you and be like
what do you think how should i do how
can i make it yeah so you guys make sure
to check out her blog she also has a
youtube channel you can check out all
the links in the description and we'll
see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
you